I made the mistake a yesterday of going
to one of the presentations on natural
language which is not my thing I'm a
DevOps guy and my life was changed
because the whole view that I had of the
way our slack bot auto work right out
the window because like there's really
cool natural language things out there
that are not that difficult to configure
I don't have to be a genius to make this
work I might actually be able to fix up
our slack bot to be more polite more
responsive and more representative of
people's intent this is like holy cow
that was completely by accident the ones
that I went to on purpose were even
better so what I really want to talk
about actually is is my home and I have
luscious pictures of Red Ranger there so
the point is that a bunch of years ago
like eight or so years ago my partner
and I decided we were gonna sell
everything we owned including the f-150
and the house and all the stuff and fit
out a boat and go see the watery parts
of the world and my mother said bless
her heart she lived about a mile from
where we lived in rural upstate New York
and the foothills the Adirondack
Mountains my mother said buy a boat and
sail around don't come home don't come
home until you have a story oh because
the first 50 years of stories have been
boring frankly steaming so you better
pick up the pace here I'm getting old
and I'm not waiting around for any good
stuff to happen any longer so what I
want to talk about is sailing because
sailing us is cool stuff and
specifically I want to talk about a
particular journey that we were on in
Red Ranger and so this is the way you
sort of think about the sailing thing
I'm trying to get from Nassau in the
Bahamas to Fernandina Beach in Florida
it's a four hundred some-odd nautical
mile trip we use nautical miles at sea
this is always a weird thing but if you
you know take the 360 degrees around the
equator and divide each degree into 60
it's each of those is one nautical mile
so it's 126 thousands the diameter of
the earth they're about six thousand
feet so it's similar to a statute mile
but you read it right directly off the
chart latitude longitude nautical miles
no thinking involved so at two o'clock
in the morning when you're not thinking
very clearly you can still read the damn
chart so this is why nautical miles are
really important and we use knots
nautical miles per hour and you'll
notice that the point up there about the
the speed that we're gonna go at when
you are able to run a 5k in 22 minutes
that's about how fast the boat goes so
we are not proceeding through the ocean
terribly quickly and the consequence of
that is is that a journey of 400 odd
nautical miles is going to take a while
I'll save you the math we do four hours
on four hours off watchkeeping so that
means that I come on at midnight and at
4:00 a.m. I wake the crewmember up the
crew member is there from 4:00 a.m. to
8:00 a.m. and it cycles around like that
through the days and so the only human
interaction you have is watch change a
brief shining moment where you wake the
other person up tell them what's going
on and then you immediately fall asleep
because four hours on four hours off
you're basically always a little
sleep-deprived and what you wind up
talking about during the watch changes a
few critical things you know the weather
and sea state which is like generally
pretty observable but a lot of times it
changes dramatically on this particular
trip when we left Nassau the wind was
blowing trade winds 20-some knots
you know like 25 miles an hour or
something like that but by the time it
was my watch the wind had died to
nothing and we had to start the diesel
engine to make the boat move at all
shipping is always a baffling mystery at
sea because there's lights everywhere
especially in the Straits of Florida and
some of those lights are just cruise
ships that are just idling they drive
out of Fort Lauderdale and they just
hang around offshore so you can like
gamble and drink and then they go back
into Fort Lauderdale they drift in the
in the in the currents it's very weird
others of them are fishing boats in
there pretty big operations there's some
container ships headed for the Port of
Miami all this has to be kind of sorted
out and at night they're just a bunch of
lights on the horizon they all look
alike for a while and then you figure it
out and then you you you you tell the
other person when you're switching watch
what exactly is going on you know how
the boat is doing is important how the
rest of the crew is doing I'm starving
what is there to eat and you know oh I
just went out during my watch I put a
pot of rice on so it's on the galley
down there undo the lid we use a
pressure cooker and you know you can
have hot rice stuff down in the galley
so these are you know important little
exchanges of information and then they
go to sleep and so at midnight the one
night I get up and and this is the watch
change information I smell burning
diesel that is a kind of an alarming
thing I thought we were gonna talk about
the weather or whether or not there was
any rice to eat I was not expecting to
talk about the smell of burning diesel
so the question you have at this point
is how in goodness name can you
correlate Python programming with
sailboats are you deranged and the
answer is perhaps I am deranged but I do
see a parallel here and the parallel is
fraught with some philosophical
difficulties software for instance
doesn't wear out boats do things
on the boat we're out at different
speeds that the whole boat thing is very
different from the software thing but I
want to talk a little bit about what we
do when we build software solutions and
how that matches up with what we do when
we builds marine solutions and how
living with software is a lot like
living with a boat and I want to
emphasize one thing is there are those
people who build software that is and
some of us are guilty of this ourselves
shabby it works but you know there's
issues and a lot of times it works when
I use it but when you use it there are
issues so
the response to the bug report is wfm
works for me that's a sure sign of
shabby software some software is just
straight-up good it does what you
expected it to do it does when you
expect it to do it it you know it worked
because you can see at work and there's
some software that is hand-wringing ly
overwrought it's got a kabillion
sometimes 1.2 kabillion extra if
statements in there to cover situations
that you're not even sure the original
author could really fully articulate
what do you think is going to be
happening here and then they'll spin
some yarn about what if some evil
software genius just work with me for a
minute what if some evil software genius
edited the configuration file so that
the imported configurations imported
another file and the other file had OS
system format in it that formatted the
hard drive while I was running huh did
you ever think of that correct me if I'm
wrong but it's Python I can read the
source I don't need to tweak the
configuration file in some deep and
mysterious way I just added the damn py
file and I am done with it your stuff
format to the hard drive every time it
runs this is not rocket science doesn't
require an evil genius to make a mess of
things I think so when we talk about
boats wearing out let's dig into a
little bit of detail on this
specifically boats don't just vaguely
wear out they have a very number of a
very specific number of threat scenarios
and often the cybersecurity people like
to talk about threat scenarios every
software application has sort of threat
scenarios sometimes it's just dumb use
cases a user is going to run it like
this and that's stupid
it still is a kind of a threat scenario
it's not like they're trying to steal
passwords but they are going to do
something dumb
and they're gonna wind up deleting their
data set so we probably ought to think
about that as a threat in broad vague
using threat in a very vague way so
threat scenarios for boats you know
corrosion and stuff electrolysis
biological attacks when you enter the
ocean you enter the food chain and you
are no longer on the top of the food
chain everything in the ocean is going
to eat you
barnacles barnacles are evil little
things it's hard to believe that
barnacles can do as much damage as they
do they didn't even have a brain or a
body they just have a shell they're
almost as bad as squid the only good
squids a dead squid just remember that
every time you order calamari if it
wasn't for us he and calamari they would
have taken over the planet millennia ago
maybe maybe not I want to talk briefly
about the cyclic loading issue you don't
think about this when you're gently
rocking on the boat in the anchorage oh
this is kind of nice yeah every one of
those rocks is a break on a chain and a
point kind of chain and a point kind of
chain and so that cyclic loading of
years of bouncing back and forth wears
out steel parts it's amazing and other
things chafe we'll talk about some of
these things and vibration and of course
the crucial and most important thing
that is damaging to a boat is dumb asset
ood because there are things that you
decide that you perhaps should not have
decided and you caused yourself more
grief than any other kind of mechanical
failure could have caused you
so boats don't really wear out they're
subject to a variety of very specific
threat scenarios including dumb asset
ood so what you have to do when you're
looking at boat problems which is like
looking at software problems you have
sort of different ways of approaching
the problem some things you want to try
to prevent by good design good choice of
components and correct assembly
techniques we'll talk about this in a
little bit some things you want to
defend against these are the operational
things you do every
you check the oil before you start the
engine purely a defensive measure
because there's no prevention that will
stop the oil from not to being there if
it's not there don't start the engine
it's a decision point so therefore it's
an operational thing
therefore it counts as a defensive
measure and there are some things that
are responses to problems where the de
preventive thing stopped working like it
wore out or got circumvented the
defensive thing didn't work because you
tried but you couldn't and now you're
off into recovery mode where you're
gonna have to do something to get back
into some kind of operational trim and
just you know to reinforce the boating
thing briefly we look at the five FS of
safety flooding fire first aid falling
overboard and anybody who's seen my five
FS of functional programming knows that
the 5 FS 5 kinds of Python functions
it's not really five but five such a
cool number there's a lot more than five
sort of defensive measures you might get
involved in but it's almost five and
some of them are similar enough to
others and categorization is hard so I'm
not going to try to classify these
properly but these are things that you
wind up having to do and you have to
think about them and you have to know
them and you have to be able to execute
them and this is where it becomes
important these aren't just sort of
arbitrary things in the background these
are things that you have intentionally
decided you're going to do you're going
to have fire extinguishers you're going
to have bilge pumps you're going to make
sure the pumps work there's defensive
measures they parallel operational
things you do with your application
software am I going to have logs am I
going to check the logs these are active
decisions you have to make and they you
want to automate as much as you can to
push things into preventative world but
not everything gets into prevention
world some things are active defensive
measures stuff
have to actually get off your Duff and
do once in a while the other part of
thinking about reliable software is
somewhere is the edge of the envelope
we're beyond this line with that
actually that line beyond this line it's
failed we can't really recover very well
in the case of the boat here an example
thing that's right on the line is when
the boat gets physically knocked over
mast laying in the water this is in the
design envelope the nautical architect
the marine architect the person who
designed the shape of the hull in the
rigging knew that getting knocked
sideways was a thing that can happen
rarely and the boat should in principle
come back up again because it's got
enough mass well it's no longer below
the waterline but it's got enough mass
countering the the mast that it should
come back up on the the trade-off though
is you can't really prevent a knockdown
unless you'd like never take the boat
into the water because it's always sort
of theoretically possible the wind and
wave combination is sucks at the boats
gonna get knocked all the way over are
the boat we lived on was knocked over in
the Chesapeake Bay and you don't think
of like hurricanes blowing ten foot seas
or thirty foot seas in the Chesapeake
Bay it wasn't it was actually a derecho
wind slam to those sideways it fell over
in the water stood back up again when
the breeze went by boats been through
two it only got knocked over in the one
I was on at the other time it wasn't
that bad because we were lucky but there
is this recovery issue when the boat
goes slamming over on its side
everything not literally nailed down is
going to go flying around the inside of
the boat we use the term not nailed down
metaphorically a lot of times no this is
literally the floorboards are going to
come off the floor the batteries are
going to come out of the engine
compartment this is a dangerous
situation but the boats going to recover
it's only dangerous for people who
happen to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time and even then you're still
gonna have to put things back together
there's a recovery mode after that thing
but that's inside the design envelope
that was a No
situation that could happen so we're not
talking about weird threat scenarios or
bizarre hacker attacks or something like
that
it's just you know the DDoS of boding it
can happen so what you have to then
think about is stuff that gets out into
weird attack Ville or weird failure mode
beyond anything that you could initially
have thought of the important thing
about beyond the edge of the envelope is
the things are not stuff you can
rationally foresee so you can't prevent
it they're things that you can put
defensive measures in place so that if
it's all kind of going south you might
be able to detect it but you're gonna be
in active recovery mode from the real
real weird stuff and so this thing with
a flask server being started in a docker
container as part of a crontab we
couldn't figure out why it wouldn't
start and run normally the doctor come
up and run for 15 minutes and then crash
come up and run for 15 minutes and crash
and you have very little visibility into
this and the whole notion of having our
crontab start a flask job is like that's
bizarre who even thought of doing that
what mindset did forget that part of it
we're never gonna know but what we have
to do is now patch the damn thing so
it'll start correctly and then we can
come off after that so there's a kind of
a workaround patch mode and for sailors
that workaround patch mode actually has
a formal name we call it jury-rigging
you will jury-rigged a solution because
if you don't jury-rigged the solution
you're going to die here so work on it
there are some hugely famous jury-rigged
things there's some great videos of
people putting together bizarre bizarre
solutions out of thought of just scraps
of parts on their boat and things like
that because you want to be able to sail
back in you want to get the engine to
run and somebody had a phone the
batteries weren't dead they're like holy
cow you're actually making that work and
yeah the movie adrift or whatever it is
that came out last December
juryrigg
out of the whisker poll and get the boat
to move and successfully get somewhere
under that the Volvo Ocean Race boats
this is a bunch of years ago but they
had left Spain and one of the boats the
carbon-fiber mast broke and so you've
got the 75 foot boat occurred twelve and
a mass that's about eight feet tall and
you're essentially in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean when it happens so now
what do you do well you've got a bunch
of skilled professional sailors so you
break out the sewing machine and you sew
a new sail that's eight feet tall and
you rig that thing to the end of the 60
foot long boom and you sail it to Brazil
to Brazil from the middle of the ocean
because that was the closest point they
could get to that's like heroic
brilliant oh my god but it was a
jury-rigged they had some parts they had
some skills they put the thing together
they got limping along and and there was
you know successful they did reasonably
well in the rest of the races even
though that that first leg they did
pretty poorly because their boat got
broken but you know they did okay so
here we are not in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean we're just in the Straits
of the Florida between Florida in the
Bahamas and it's it's midnight and it's
it's dark and the crew says I smell
diesel fuel and I of course shot my
mouth off being the tech nerd I am we
have a diesel engine of course you smell
diesel fuel that's the kind of attitude
that will get you punched do not
mansplain diesel fuel to the crew never
this is an important lesson life lesson
never mansplain diesel fuel so we went
through the five FS of safety because
this is what we do it's a it's a smart
thing to do we're not physically on fire
and a diesel fuel doesn't burn easily it
burns only a huge pressure and huge
temperatures which is why it's really a
cool safe fuel safe from the gasoline
we're not technically flooded the bilge
pumps are working and there isn't that
much diesel in the in the deep bilge
we're both here nobody's fallen
overboard and we're not actively falling
overboard we have our offshore harnesses
on and our jack lines and we're all safe
there I'm okay no first-aid required for
me you have to be a little cautious
working around these
engines because diesel fuels that a huge
huge pressure and it'll it'll cut you
actually if it's spring because the
pressure is so high and it'll take out
your eyes so yeah you know safety
glasses and you have the hair and the
turning metal parts and stuff so there's
but none of that happens there's the
fatigue question it's midnight are you
capable of dealing with this the answer
is yeah I had four hours of good sleep
so I'm ready to go let's let's start on
this the famine question there's rice on
the stove you good I'm good
so we're in to fix mug so what are the
pythonic lessons from this I gotta say
those are some fine-looking pictures
right design did we design the thing the
right way to begin with do we know where
the design envelope is what are the
situations where this should work
correctly completely do we understand
that part of it right component
selection are we using the right tools
for the right job and this is because we
are parts of the Python community and
python is batteries included computing
and oh my god the standard library may
be big but the whole Python ecosystem is
vast beyond the comprehension of mere
mortals you have to choose wisely and
then there's the Python 2 question which
anybody here still using Python - I will
shame you publicly if you still are and
the a proper assembly technique in the
boating thing because of cyclic loading
in the vibration and and and the remote
possibility of having to work in you
know a wet environment assembly is
really really important a lot of
stainless steel parts and stuff is
essential and you know you don't just
have wires randomly they have led to be
supported and stuff like that
and in Python world that assembly thing
also applies because we are gluing
together software components and we have
to be cognizant of the interfaces among
those software components
and there are some things we can do and
we know because we've done them that are
a little sketchy where I'm just gonna
quickly put this little JSON file into
this other thing and the other thing is
actually expecting the animal but
because JSON is a subset of yam well
it's gonna work okay and then it's going
to turn it into a CSV and eventually
this is all gonna fit together could we
have maybe cut some of the middle stuff
out and just glued them together
correctly like they're supposed to be
glued together right assembly is as much
a part of right component selection is
as much a part of right design all of it
sort of got to be there if you want to
have something survivable so design wise
I mentioned the standard libraries I
think it's really really important to
understand what's available in the
standard library and choose wisely when
you're not using something that's
already part of the standard library I'm
kind of biased that way for the proper
data science though you know numpy and
pandas and the stuff we use all the time
scikit-learn they're not in the standard
library so you know we're already
outside the trivial case and into the
interesting case so you have to think
carefully there but what's really
important is that not inventing a new
wheel this has to be done judiciously
and so you will hear people give
presentations about a dumb idea they had
that's not without value because the
dumb ideas are not without value but the
question is in some cases why start down
that road in the first place there's
stuff that's available there's stuff
that's widely used it's got a million
stars on github maybe it's better to do
that than invent your own eye
I'm always suspicious you know in the
sprint planning when somebody says what
we're just gonna build this and it'll be
great yeah but there's stuff that's a
lot like that why is this so much better
these are valuable conversations to have
so boding wise you know there's a bunch
of choices that have to be made you're
buying a high tensile strength steel and
you're using nylon and stuff like that
my boat has five sails so I've got tons
and tons of nylon line everywhere our
ground tackle is you know this
combination of chain and rope
so that we have a lot of weight at one
end and not much weight at the other end
zinc anodes in order to make sure that
electrolysis doesn't happen and things
like that the the biocide paint to make
sure the barnacles don't eat any more of
the boat than they're supposed to and
these are all essentially component
selection things you buy the right parts
you buy them from a known marine place
and you put them together the right way
this isn't that hard to do it's actually
kind of fun I mentioned that that
there's a fatigue and chafe issue that
you got to make sure everything's
anchored correctly and you've got to use
all the right sort of seizing and if
you're tying stuff together with ropes
you got to use the right knots and
whatnot there's a lot to it it's not
that difficult to do and it's a lot like
ordinary programming in that there are
these specific programming techniques
data structures algorithms api's these
are all the ordinary skills that you
build up using tools like Python and you
just have to execute them reasonably
well each time when you go through pull
request design reviews and and
discussions with other people you
improve your skills each time and do a
better job of assembly the next time the
the same thing is true for for putting
stuff together on a boat and you have
some other higher-level
more powerful tools available to
validate that you're doing things the
right way you know you use pilant or PI
flake you use my PI I used to be a big
unit test person but I switched over to
PI tests and I'm really happy I did so
you put all of these things together to
you know make sure that you've assembled
your code correctly big fan of type-ins
anybody else here I asked earlier
yesterday about who's using type it's a
couple of people are yeah yeah yeah this
is you there are some things that are
very difficult to do with type to
describe with type hints and it's sort
of okay to take a step back from the
really hard edge cases if you're going
to invent a new kind of decorator for
instance you're going to discover the
type hints for decorators is its own
weird world of meta descriptions of
abstract descriptions of classic
callable objects that call callable
objects and stuff it's brutal to get the
type hints right but for other
for ordinary things you know it takes in
an integer and a float and produces the
strengths isn't rocket science you give
it to my PI and my PI says you know on
line 152 you're giving it a tuple no I'm
not oh wait I am no I'm not no no that's
not a tuple that's oh yeah I guess it is
hmm I hate you my pie this code pass
unit test this code passed unit test 80%
code coverage and now my PI is coming at
me oh no oh no I don't know we're not
putting up with that any longer than we
have to I'm gonna take out the type in
some trust that stuff right off before I
listen to my PI telling me that's not
gonna work oh but then when you put the
other unit test case in yeah it does
break all right fine
so my PI can be right once in a while I
have to mention this because it it it
was something that I thought was a
really good idea when I started using
Python 20 years ago was oh I can put
assertions everywhere what a dumb idea
don't put assertions everywhere when you
do use assertions do not assert types
and ever it is a needless restriction on
what things are gonna happen my PI will
check your types for you more more
adroitly than that assertions ever will
and because you can turn assertions off
with the optimization switch they're
there they have a place and the places
in the unit testing framework that's
where they belong PI test uses
assertions that's the right place for
them use them very very wisely so the
other part of this beside choosing the
right components having a good design
and doing good assembly is knowing where
the edge of the envelope is and where
you have crossed over the line from
ordinary operations into this is so dumb
I'm not going to try to prevent it I'm
just going to crash elaborately there is
nothing more useful than a loud
elaborate failure with a full trace back
and SNS notifications if you use Amazon
Cloud or emails or whatever you got to
do to tell people that we died here for
a good
and the good reason if somebody did the
wrong thing and that is a very very
helpful thing to do so you have two sub
cases there one is it's scary and weird
but it's still legit operations and then
there's the other one
which is I believe we're sinking and I
believe it's time to get the ditch bag
and the inflatable life raft ready and
you need to make that decision carefully
and in some cases there's this straddle
II thing where I think we can fix it but
if we can't get the ditch bag ready no I
think it's almost fixed I don't know no
ditch bet so these are these are touchy
situations and and it you have to
acknowledge them and you have to build
software that works well under all of
those circumstances and we'll talk about
this just a little bit in a moment here
the trick is to think about where that
worst case is that's still inside the
envelope that I'm willing to go this far
and we ought to be able to recover and
everything ought to be normal here
you're gonna have to do some heroic
stuff to get the database squared away
and we're gonna have to roll back some
transactions I don't know what's gonna
happen and here everything is so corrupt
that we're gonna have to just go back to
the other server because I can't like we
can't make this work anymore and so
you're talking about some detection
you're talking about some ordinary
defensive measures to get things under
control and you're also talking about
having a way when you're in that
recovery mode to do meaningful recovery
steps that aren't a first-class part of
the operation there's sort of this weird
extra tier of hackery
but it's hackery that you thought about
there is an interface for that there is
a way to put this module together you
could have a little spike thing over
here saying you know if it gets really
dicey here's this thing you can do this
thing calls that thing doesn't use the
filter and you can still process some
data
but but you're gonna have erroneous
transactions go through maybe that's not
a wrong thing to have available exposing
some of the internal component tree
designing your classes in a way that
they can be combined flexibly thinking
about functional composition of what if
I need to leave this out or what if I
need to plug something in and kind of an
emergency where I'm just going to write
a couple of lines of code and slap it in
there and it ought to work it means that
you're sort of think about doc tests
greater than greater than greater than
example a little more seriously saying
well way if we're in recovery mode
somebody really is literally going to be
typing at the greater than greater than
greater than prompt import this import
this other thing define this function
and it should run and that may be part
plus you a part of your recovery plan is
that this stuff is actually kind of
supported it's at the edge of the
envelope only do it if you're recovering
for an emergency but it is something
that we thought about when we were
designing the software in the first
place
so in in the case of things like boats
we have as a defensive measure bilge
pumps and you can see that I've got like
a kabylia noses there but they're held
together with hose clamps I can with a
screwdriver take this apart and
reassemble the plumbing if it got to
that case like I kind of wish it
wouldn't ever get to that case but
remember this is what I woke up to at
midnight I smell burning diesel Thank
you Thank You Commodore so let us review
did we detect it yes we did it was a
smell not a code smell metaphorically it
was a literal smell but I mean the whole
code smell burning diesel smell come on
this is the where we live we look at
something and we say hmm your code has a
kind of a burning diesel smell about it
is this the right thing is this what we
should do operationally software will
have smells where but it's the third
time we've seen that exception this week
hmm
what was the last thing we did
was that a patch was that a proper
release is something changed in our user
community is that just that one guy who
always does the one bad thing or is this
something else going on you know there's
a smell you probably ought to respond to
it
detection is difficult and you don't
want to have too many alarms because
then it becomes like noisy and
disturbing but on the other hand you
want to have enough alarms that you can
say mm-hmm I don't think this is right
what what should be going on here what
should be different so we detected it
can we jury-rigged around it it's the
damn fuel line to the damn diesel engine
there is no bypassing it if we bypass it
we drift in the Gulf Stream and we wind
up in Beaufort North Carolina if we're
lucky in two weeks so no no we there is
no bypass for this thing there is no
jury-rigged and in this case the rescue
tape diesel fuel is basically kerosene
it's like a solvent and so the rescue
tape was just sliding off and down there
putting tape on as this thing's
thundering away and the diesel spraying
on the block and it slips down and it
you know a couple of those tries and
like alright that's not working so now
the question is should we shut down the
engine well if you do the feels gonna
leak out the hole and we're gonna have
air in there and air in a diesel fuel
line is a huge pain in the neck I don't
want to have to bleed the engine we're
not losing that much fuel so let's just
leave a run so now the question is where
can we limp to and the answer was Stuart
Florida not too far away and you know
you're at 1:00 a.m. or 1:30 am looking
at the computerized chart plot or trying
to figure out what the closest spot in
Florida you can get to is and and then
the one other thing was to kill a
circuit breaker around the bilge pump so
that we didn't turn this into an
environmental disaster by pumping diesel
fuel overboard from our boat because
that's only a ten thousand dollar fine
we did have to clear customs that was
awkward and confusing because we're
trying to get in to this thing in
Florida we've been up all night and you
know and of course the engine's not
right and the Coast Guard wants to board
our boat and inspect it and like oh my
god not now this is not but what else
you gonna do so okay come on bring the
guns
about whatever you guys got to do make
yourselves happy so you need to be able
to detect the problems more than just a
smell some logging some alerts some
filters Splunk data dog whatever you got
for detection employ it liberally
because you can't go too far wrong
just have it filterable and silence
above when the errors don't make sense
sometimes you'll put stuff in as a
release and it turns out it's not really
helpful you maybe want to take it out or
silence it like the Python warnings
module some things you don't need to
hear about every single time some things
you do because they're legit you need to
be able to respond to it and so you need
to be able to make decisions make stuff
work and I've highlighted in red here
top-level CLI scripting I'm a firm firm
believer because I'm old in having some
kind of CLI capability and I don't care
what your thing is if it could be a very
fancy single page app or you've got a
really cool API server that coughs out
some JavaScript code that does the rest
of the work I still think in the
background you ought to have some CLI
tools to square away state user access
controls security provisions API keys
all the other stuff ought to be done
outside the users view of the world that
in the back I've got this thing and the
thing that I've got in the back the CLI
probably ought to be very carefully
secured because you don't want a
backdoor that any idiot can get at you
probably want a CLI that can only be
used by a few users who log in to just
the right account with the ssh a--'s
with the certificate you gave them so
that only a few people on the planet can
use the CLI but the fact remains they
can use the CLI they have access to get
at the things behind the hood under the
hood in the engine room rebuild the
stuff just to get limping so that we're
not completely dead in the water we're
not compromising people's personal
information
we're not giving away credit card
numbers or some other foolish
but we have control over it so limping
home jury-rigging is important and I
emphasize a CLI script that you probably
ought to do it so when you're building
things like web servers have a CLI
capability flask does this for free it's
not difficult to do so do it make sure
that there are potentially reusable
components the whole point of micro
services is to not have monoliths the
whole point of Python is to not have
giant monolithic piles of code you're
importing different modules bust your
modules down a little bit include some
higher-level access maybe some functions
maybe some class definitions so that
from the greater greater greater prompt
you can actually do some meaningful
stuff recover your database reset your
credentials turn stuff back off again so
that you have control over what's going
on these are three essentially identical
boats all on one mooring ball in Vero
Beach that's about a hundred thousand
pounds of boat or something like that
tied to that ball the good news is that
it's way inland so you don't get any any
a big breeze but what when we put the
third boat on there we were all
scratching our heads going you know the
marina management people are going to
hate us if something happens because
those are those are right big boats and
that's not a right big ball software
doesn't break doesn't wear out when you
uncover a problem the problem had
already been there and has always been
there this sometimes is a troubling
thing because you uncover it and then
you say Oh drat how much of the database
has corrupt how long has this been going
on
so that's an unpleasant thing and it
means that ordinary defensive
programming adding a bunch of random
search statements and stuff like that
isn't gonna help it not going to solve
the problem it's not going to
the problem is just gonna add a lot of
code that makes perhaps detection more
difficult so don't get too involved in
the defensive programming because you're
gonna have to patch it you're gonna have
to put out a repair you may have to redo
some of the stuff in the database when
you figure out the extent of the damage
but all of that activity is colored by
certain knowledge that the bug was
always there it just took you a while to
discover it important rule it didn't
wear out it was always broken so the
other thing is explicitly empower the
capability of jury-rigging your stuff
make your components reusable make your
components recombine a ball think
through the beyond the edge of the
envelope scenario saying well you know
if everything goes to hell here's what
we can do we can this and we can that
and we'll get it back up and running
again it's not a bad thing the fact that
you can think through it means you've
put the software together in a way that
that recombination that jury-rigging is
possible that is the right way to design
software as reusable components
recombine a ball we're always taught
that anyway we just don't often think
about the idea of jury-rigged and
linking limping home but you can think
about me in the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean trying to get my engine back
together again you're talking about
operational sort of runtime tweaks and
repairs and things like that you always
want to prevent I mean duh so you want
to make sure that you've done right
design you've selected the right
components you've assembled things the
right way that there's you know that
this is you know motherhood and apple
pie this is what you're supposed to have
been doing but it doesn't always work
that way so make sure that you have
thought carefully about detecting the
problem make sure that you have thought
carefully about what you're gonna do to
maybe work in a degraded mode if that's
what you need to do and how do we
abandon ship what is the process for
rolling back to the previous version
where is the old database what are the
old database credentials what happens
when we
back to version 1.1 and we're using the
1.1 database and all the transactions
aren't there anymore
how do we tell the pissed-off users that
the stuff you did last week is gone
forever because of some other problem
it's a thought exercise you may never
have to do it but you should think about
degraded mode what will our failover be
how do we abandon ship what order do we
get things from below where is our
wallet and our passport is it in the
ditch bag at all times really awkward
it's just a weekend I'm just going
sailing where is the wallet go it goes
in the waterproof bag as a matter of
discipline so that you always know where
your wallet is it's in the waterproof
bag so that when we leave the boat that
bag goes first life raft goes second the
one on the left is not my boat in fact
none of those are my boat
Israel taken from my boat these we just
you know if anybody's been to Annapolis
you'll recognize the the picture in the
lower right hand corner well thank you
very much I hope you have begun to think
a little bit about how you might be
jury-rigging how you might be limping
home how you might be detecting problems
and we will talk a nun we're gonna have
lightning talks and then we're gonna
have social hour at the beer garden and
I will meet you out in the hall thank
you
[Applause]